on Becky from Full House taken into
custody by FBI agents that is the
sentence that I never thought would come
out of my mouth I'm here at the federal
courthouse in downtown Los Angeles where
Lori Lachlan appeared in court today
just one day after Felicity Huffman
faced the judge we have the latest on
both stars and their alleged roles in
the largest College cheating scam in
history he was a mom it doesn't seem
like you've had very many pitfalls oh
thank you very much I mean we've had our
moments you could say today was a moment
Lori Lachlan surrendered to the FBI and
was taken into custody next top federal
court in downtown LA Laurie's case was
caught a little after 3 p.m. Pacific and
frankly she looked like someone whose
world had been turned upside down in the
last 24 hours
her bond was set at a million dollars
the same as her husband and she will be
allowed to travel to British Columbia to
complete work today's hearing is of
course a day after Lori's husband and
Felicity Huffman posted bail and were
released Laurie was in Vancouver filming
garage-sale mystery for the hallmark
movies and mystery Channel when the
bombshell sting operation unfolded
yesterday
the couple allegedly paid $500,000 to
get their daughters into USC now in the
wake of the scandal both Lori and
Felicity's past TV roles are coming back
to haunt them asking for bribe
pretending you're above that I've got my
checkbook we may have well he may have
embellished lied a bit on our
application
it only shows you want what's best for
your boys then there's what Laurie and
her two daughters Isabelle in Olivia
told ET back in 2016 what is the best
advice that your mom is giving you be
classy and your reputation never fades
if you get slapped with a stigma or
something negative you can't you it's
hard to recover so and also I always
tell them in this day and age online it
doesn't go away
Lori's youngest daughter Olivia is
learning that lesson the hard way I
don't know how much of school I'm gonna
attend I don't really care about school
as you guys know the USC freshman and
YouTube star is taking a ton of online
heat for seemingly profiting off her
dorm life today Amazon is coming to
shoot some of my room because it hooked
me up with like basically everything in
my dorm so how was the rest of Hollywood
handling the admissions scandal we know
a lot of people in that circle and it
was really shocking today and now
cleaning Kyle Richards who dropped her
daughter Sofia off at George Washington
University
on last night's Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills was asked about the
scandal on watch what happens live
you're friends with Lauri
yeah and they're really great people and
you kind of go I'm a little confused by
by all of this and until today had never
heard this ever existed minutes later
someone asks Kyle on Twitter can you
please confirm that all your children
got into college on their own
Kyle answered 1,000,000% my eldest fare
graduated magna [ __ ] laude from USC Kelly
Ripa who has two kids in college
defended herself to a paparazzo I know
you work super hard to get your kids
into school and they did their best
sound
I know Rob Lowe however threw a little
shade his children attended Duke and
Stanford and in a tweet he has since
deleted he wrote very proud of my honest
hard-working sons and late night had a
field day well it looks like Felicity
Huffman and Lori Loughlin are headed
back to TV
Laughlin allegedly got her daughter's
into USC through the rowing team even
though her daughter never rode a boat
how the school's felt for these photo
shops I don't know I mean use your heads
people we will continue to follow this
unbelievable story as it develops
[Applause]
[Music]